знову не громадян та україни сну але мені
представляю ряду чиновник аллаха ви
знаєте навіть голову за раз каже ей
відсоток бюджет реально там ще кожну
руку їхати на дієту чоловіка але хочу вас
навчилася, а працюйте з виставкою
знайшлося пофарбуватися алана шкода шкірного
хіба ти ж не не не ми чуємо лучник не
знаючи висоти бюджетні інвестиції в люди
ну в краї ну мої будні ну desnude на
інвестиції в люди ну і ми новизна та мої
взяття любин і з вати владимир
зелений метінвест і повний апсид
диких речах упертих людей ось дуже
сталеву прокуратуру
офіс генерального прокурора не багато не
мало на 2 мільярди гривень і також
катки на службу україни ну на всіх ти
хто
замовив
для нього
потрібно ми чуємо
інвестиції в краї
як україну друзі
Білорусь і в Російську федерацію
завиткам обирається скуповувати на
електроенергію пізніше в ту ricci ну через
ікла будемо немає ствол і колосального
всіх любить в іконою турецькі
компанії вона українські компанії в я до
Україні ну ми інвестуємо виключити на
південь вічка я хочу cove тут інвестиції у
україну я знаю шов інвестиції в
енергоефективність друзі два з
половиною мільярда гривень cfc
одна тисячна ввп при тому ще ціна на
газ пари було тисячу доларів світла
до того ж зростають сяннань енергоносії
і ми сьогодні за лижні виду нерва
носили край він там ще означає з нас
затискають і холодно бюджет вклади
ефективність інвестицій інвестиції
більше не ви до будку лозу дивани ти
інвестицію в основу рами слові сьогодні
на складах нічого я абсолютно і тому
колиму тримав
3 трильйони гривень трильйони
всі шкірки громадян україни видно дасть
річкову бабусі
75 тисяч гривень та
фракції
фракція верховної ради та як
бачите все
ці
люди можуть